welcome to another dr sadler's honest
review this is a book review series in
which i look at and talk about
mostly recent works in what we can call
practical philosophy very broadly
speaking ranging from very rigorous work
and applications of ancient and other
philosophy to contemporary life and its
problems all the way over to
organizational psychology leadership
self-help and everything in between
and the book that i'm going to review
this time may seem a little bit outside
of that scope but i actually think it
does kind of fit in there it is a very
recently released book uh elliot
rosenstocks the ego
and its hyperstate subtitled a
psychoanalytically informed dialectical
analysis of self-interest which is quite
a mouthful there
and it's come out just recently from
zero books
so you know 2021 and i got an advanced
copy of it and i've read it through
several times so i'm going to talk about
the
usual three s's style substance summary
some of the key points that the book is
making what i think is good about the
book and then any aspects that i myself
found problematic
i think in looking at the three s's it
might be best to begin with some kind of
summary
of this rather short work we're talking
about 112 pages total the the rest of
the book is is zero books advertising
its other books and this long title
might be
in the one respect illuminating and in
other respects confusing for some people
so
i also think that it could be good to
look at the blurb that's on the back so
the ego and its hyper state right off
the bat that kind of you know is
reminiscent for those who are in the
know of the ego and its own or the ego
and its property of mock sterner and
strinner will be mentioned later on in
the book and so maybe you could see this
as trying to carry out something
analogous to that he's talking a lot in
this book about
self-interest
which is also mentioned in the subtitle
a
psychoanalytically informed
dialectical analysis of self-interest so
we've got three terms there all of which
are going to be
quite important self-interest is really
the
central theme of the work what does
genuine or
authentically understood or properly
analyze self-interest mean
self-interest turns out to be something
that is misunderstood from the
perspective of rosen stock and arguably
from the perspective of many of the
other people that he is
invoking here and these two terms that
are coming up psychoanalysis dialectical
those i think are
you know good to have in the title
because
they reveal the main
modes of analysis that are going on in
the work so it is doing some some work
that is not directly psychoanalysis
itself which is of course a practice
but is informed by psychoanalytic theory
and then dialectical um the main
dialectician who gets mentioned in here
quite a bit is hegel but it's not only
hegelian dialectics you could say that
are that are running the show in this
and um dialectical analysis
means that there is a focus on how
things actually unfold
so not beginning from
rigid
starting points that you know once
they're established they last forever
instead we we see how ideas transform
themselves how they give rise to and
engage with what appear to be their
opposites how they can be brought into
larger complexes and how those
themselves may not be the end of the
analysis
the back blurb is is actually quite good
i think as well
instead of having a bunch of people
saying
mostly false things about how amazing
the book is the way most books are it
tells you what the book is about so i'm
just going to read it to you
the ego in its hyperstate is a unified
theory of psychological and ethical
egoism which posits self-interest the
dialectical dream theory sets its sights
against capitalist notions of the
self-interest contra the other not
simply with moralism but with a more
accurate analysis of the subject of
self-interest that has been provided by
capitalists and anarchist theorists
alike through the lens of psychoanalysis
and hegelian dialectical logic the
process of self-interest at the ground
of all human existence reveals itself
eliot rosenstock has a symptom he wants
you to know about he wants you to know
how the nature of self-interest strikes
through the notions of pure duty and
state worship he wants to bring in
psychoanalysis and redeem dialectics in
its power to reveal the universe rather
than to be a simple rhetorical tool and
he wants to reveal to you how the
material conditions of the world as well
as psychological processes of mankind
work together to bring about all that is
brought into the universe by humanity so
there's a couple points there that are
worth
hitting on
the very first sentence a unified theory
of psychological and ethical egoism
um the very last part revealed to you
how the material conditions of the world
psychological processes of mankind work
together to bring about all that is
brought into the universe by humanity so
you know like in theory what this book
should be
talking about is in fact the totality
and now does it bring that off in a
hundred pages
arguably not but you know that would be
an awful lot to do even in volumes and
volumes and volumes of things
what else should we say about this so
let's jump into talking about the
structure so
it's revealed pretty
straightforwardly by the table of
content it begins with a very important
introduction in which um
rosenstock is
instead of like saying well in chapter
one i do this in chapter two i do this
he jumps right in and starts introducing
you to the key ideas
of the work and what it is supposed to
be
helping you to understand there's also
some good framing
here he talks about the self-interest
camp in my personal circles is very
split and we'll come back to that in
just a moment
after this this introduction which you
know runs about nine pages um there's
part one which is a shorter part
compared to part two
essential properties of psychoanalytic
self-interest and this makes sense the
way that it it starts so there are um
[Music]
how many
suddenly blank on the number yeah there
are there are four
chapters to that the freudian molecule
which is bringing in this idea about you
know composition of things and also
going into some psychoanalytic stuff the
negativity of the will very interesting
chapter the positivity of the demand and
ideology
in wonderland and these are rather
evocative titles but they do tell you
what he is focusing on as he's slowly
building together the
components of or the dimensions of the
analysis and in each of these he will be
telling us something about what
self-interest is supposed to be what it
extends to
and bringing in other concepts
then we have part two which is titled
dialectical egoism vectors of
self-interest and that has
four
main
subsections to it
which are of uh different sizes
two of them have
five chapters one has three chat
chapters and one has four chapters and
that leads us from chapter five to
chapter 21 and these chapters are pretty
short most of them
so they are you think of them as like
sort of individual studies that are
grouped together under this the first
part is universal moments
make sense you know looking at these
sort of broad concepts and here's where
he gets well i should i'll just read you
the chapter titles the ego substance and
articulating the symptom okay so there
we've got something that's both
dialectical and psychoanalytic
egoism as an entrance an escape super
ego as a unity again you know something
uh
sort of located in a broadly freudian
psychoanalysis the negative power of
myth the hyperstate's relation to myth
that's the entirety of that and then we
have this thing called the good cause
which is three chapters put together and
that's that's quite interesting this
plays an important
role it's signifying a kind of
recurring dynamic within
any self-interested
human being's purview you could say then
we move to the communal and the
interpersonal and he talks about
agreements identity order that's a very
short sort of analytic chapter then he
discusses friendships and romantic
relationships with that earth mastery
the you know sort of environmental stuff
the beautiful there's a very interesting
chapter there an order contra identity
finally the last main section
is pure unconscious rational force here
we're getting more and more
metaphysical um and it's you know the
the very last chapter is the absolute
hyper state so you know you'd expect to
see that in something called the ego and
the hyper state and then he finishes up
with something called afterwards the
good place which is connected to the
good cause but is also talking about the
good place and this is where i should
mention that he does bring in quite a
few
examples from pop culture
films books
social media even gets discussed in this
so that's that's i think an important
factor
in understanding these things you know
for example he discusses gladiator he
just discusses castaway
he discusses several different
television shows and other media things
now i should talk about style
and i will get to
discuss this a bit more when we get to
the good and the
problematic it is definitely a book that
is written in a what we can call a
broadly continental style there's a good
bit of jargon involved here that
functions sort of like a
code as somebody who's been
reading and teaching about and writing
about continental philosophy for roughly
30 years
for me
i was able to
you know quickly get all the references
but even then sometimes you're not quite
sure where this is supposed to be going
or what's supposed to be interpreted i
would say that it's
it's fairly clear for something that is
written in that way because sometimes
continental philosophy
and you know cultural analysis can be
really just sort of circling one's tale
with a lot of jargon um there's a lot of
sort of elusiveness and illusion
which kind of makes sense given
what rosenstein has to say drawing again
on dialectical and you know
psychoanalytic ideas about the nature of
reality and its relation to
myth and to fantasy
um so
you know you should just be kind of
forewarned i don't think that it is
impenetrable
but it is going to be
challenging for some readers because of
the nature of its
style so that's probably enough about
the
big three s's at this point
so what are some of the really key ideas
i'm obviously not going to lead you
through the entirety of the book it's a
pretty rich and dense work for its uh
brevity of of a little over a hundred
pages
um but i think that you know there's
some things that i can highlight as
particularly
central so he begins in the very you
know start with the introduction some
causal remarks about this text existing
rather than not existing it talks about
self-interest being foundational to
understanding the question of why
something which is created by human
beings exists so it's a metaphysical as
well as moral
question and this is a book devoted to
trying to understand
self-interest in a
non-knee-jerk non-naive non-one theory
to cover every single thing
uh sort of way but something that's
going to be delving
into it and which works within a culture
in which self-interest already has a
number of different ways in which it is
looked at and so i mentioned this
passage before the self-interest camp in
my personal circles is very split those
who love to hear people talk about
things in terms of self-interest need no
convincing at the further elucidation of
this idea which runs throughout reality
right so the people who are cool on
self-interest they're not that
interested in hearing additional
explanations about it because they want
to treat it as a
brute concept sort of foundational there
are others who seem to really like to
hear me talk about other subjects within
philosophy and psychology and appear to
glaze over when i bring up the idea of
self-interest these people ask me
questions about their lives and
foundation of reality and what to do
next but when i hit the essence of the
answer to that question which is to say
the notion of self-interest it is like a
great shot of
anti-reality ideology pulses through
them and you know
we should ask the question and and i
think rosenstock is doing here
why is self-interest looked at as such a
dirty word why
why isn't there some sort of legitimate
self-interest and how do we figure out
what that would be
and one key to this he says
is that we
we want to think of self-interest
as a
concept that is a process
um and so you know instead of seeing it
as something that we can explain right
off the bat and then take his
foundational and everything's nice and
clear after that
no it's it's a leading thread if we want
to use husserl's term right a lightning
font and
helping us to make our way through the
complex phenomena and he tells us that
our
self-interest distorts all logics and
bends all logics towards it which i
think is a wonderful way of talking
about things yes it is always there and
it's often contingent your self-interest
is not necessarily the same as mine and
the way it bends logics towards it would
not be the same
and you know he goes on
and he brings in another concept early
on
the hyper state so i'm going to read a
little bit about this because
ego egoism self-interest i think those
are all terms we're quite familiar with
the hyperstate
what does that signify so
he tells us that
the ego has various things which it
concerns itself with and becomes various
processes the jumping and movement as
well as it's overlapping and becoming
these processes is
the ego's hyperstate
it's not that the ego has its hyperstate
but the ego is its hyperstate it may be
an image but it's also a process
and so he says we'll be investigating
the ego not as an image but in its
movements and forms of other things
which become
the concrete material of self-interest
and which is a process we can know as
its hyperstate we can know these naughty
toxin plural hyperstates as the real
movement of ideals in the world
producing meaning as they produce
symptoms so does this tell us is this a
definition of the hyperstate not exactly
but it starts to tell us what are we
actually looking at here
the hyperstate is
in a way the the way the ego manifests
itself
and it's also these these various
processes he's got a couple other uh
mentions of this important concept
that i i wanted to point out a little
bit later on
so in chapter 9 the hyperstate's
relation to myth he calls it
the totality of the intrinsic logic of
self-interest
and thus specifically contrary to myth's
tendency to an anti-rational
view so he's positioning it in relation
to myth but he says myth is in fact an
articulation of the hyperstate so myth
is you could say an irrational
largely unconscious
manifestation of the hyperstate clearly
in that case hyperstate is not just of
my ego or your ego but of a whole bunch
of egos connected together
he goes on further and he says that the
hyper state pushes movements into the
foreground right
and so
it it's got a certain agency to it as
well again
hyperstate
intricately intricately connected with
the
ego a little bit later
[Music]
in the section on friendships he once
again talks about the hyperstate the
logic
of the actual movement of self-interest
and he says it manifests in our choices
and the choices which are made for us
without our consultation so there's this
i think that's a good way of signifying
that the hyperstate is uh you could say
a concretization
of the ego but it's also a way in which
the ego is connected up with the rest of
reality so choices that i make are part
of my hyper state but
there's a lot of choices that are made
for me that are part of my contingency
or facticity and they are also part of
that the things that have been you could
say imposed upon me
um there's a lot of other important
concepts that get brought up
that of
rationality there's there's a great
discussion about the relationship
between rationality and irrationality
occurring early on
from a
both a a psychoanalytic perspective and
a hegelian dialectical perspective
it's not as if rationality is just
something that we automatically have by
virtue of being human beings it's
rationality is kind of an achievement
and it's one that's
really never finished and that is very
reflected in this you which means that
you can always bring more rationality to
what appears to be
irrational and what we know
as reality
isn't all there is to reality
as well you know what we call fantasy or
imagination or even falsehood
and this would include a lot of cultural
products what we understand as myth in a
broad sense that is also part of and
intricately connected with reality and
rationality
is part of how we approach these things
but it's always as i mentioned a partial
rationality
there's also this thing that he calls
the ego substance
um
which you know is uh so he's got the
whole chapter the ego substance and
articulating the symptom he says when we
discuss egoism we have to talk about a
usage
the use of an object a conscious
engagement with a system that is
self-interest the elements of
self-interest already exist within
consciousness and articulate and
articulated within the world but the
bridging of this gap is also
self-interest the actual movement of
people within this gap and so he goes on
and he says this final cause
is something which is articulated with
various purposes and materials in mind
but the gap between this and instability
of the articulation with regards to its
usage
is the substance of self-interest which
is to say this is an essential property
of the
ego substance again not not defining
anything here just sort of evoking it
but the ego substance
is going to be playing a important role
he talks about it again at other places
for example
later on
in order versus identity he'll say the
ego substance is made up of positive and
negative identity with negative identity
being the more powerful since the
positive identity makes a promise in the
form of an articulated identification of
the self one falls short you can never
actually fully grasp yourself and the
images and words that we tell ourselves
about what it is that we are they always
turn out to be kind of false
what else
needs to be talked about this this idea
of the good cause something that we're
easily identifying ourselves with and
our self-interest in
furthering and which sort of ratifies
our self-interest and then you know
whatever is opposed to it is is going to
be bad and against our self-interest
this is an interesting notion as well
because what we have is a dialectic
between
you know you could say
naked
selfish self-interest
and something greater than ourselves as
we say it and rosenstock points out that
anytime you're buying into it secretly
in the in the basis there is some
background of self-interest but it can
be transformed and on the other hand
this is very hegelian the sort of
universal that you're supposed to be
identifying with and giving up yourself
to well that always turns out to be
rather particular and contingent as well
and
none of these are perfectly
realizable realizing the good cause
would actually mean the end of the good
cause
something else that that kind of caught
my idea and besides the fact that you
know there's all these interesting ways
of exploring what self-interest is and
what it's supposed to be sort of
revealing larger and larger levels to it
is this rather schopenhauerian
discussion of beauty in the chapter that
is about the beautiful
and
he's got this in bold he says where
there's an interest in the beautiful
one pulls oneself out of immiseration
there's a
pseudo-masochism in knowing the beauty
and it's split from being the beauty to
a certain extent but there can be a
recognition of oneself
to some extent in the beauty
making beauty in and for itself as it is
for the other for the person gazing on
it so this is
some interesting meditations on stuff
and it's only slightly show up in howery
and you know schopenhauer famously
thought that life pretty much sucks i
went into great detail why you know
blind will all those sort of things but
we could lose ourselves in aesthetic
contemplation or in practical activity
and forget about that for a while and
this is doing this is articulating
something a bit related to it but also
you know articulating a a different
possibility
the self can make the ideal and beauty
actual he says right
so those are some
i think this gives you a flavor of what
the book is about what some of the key
ideas are
and that's probably enough of that for
now
let's talk now about some of the good
features of the book and i'm going to
say right off the bat
that this is a book that rewards
re-readings as it gets better as you
read it again
i
was
you know as i was reading through it the
first time i think there were some
things that i
didn't see where things were going or i
didn't catch and i felt it was
some of it was a bit disjointed or a bit
too dependent on you know using jargon
as kind of kind of a bridge
to
get you to where the the author wants
you to go but on the the second full
reading and then my partial readings of
portions of the work i think it's
actually
way more coherent and
you know well put together i mean it's
very well written to begin with
but
you can write something quite well
without there being
an internal
coherence and connection right
and then also a connection to
reality which is what the book is
supposed to be helping us into so i
think it's actually quite good in that
respect
i don't know that every reader will be
will be willing to put in the work but
it is you know nice and short
112 pages right
so there's some points where you might
say i don't buy into this but
the book
is resilient enough as a complex that
there can be some things where you're
like yeah
this needs to be put aside but you can
still get an awful lot
out of it
so i think that's that's quite good and
another thing that i
really do like about the book is i think
that
instead of providing what it's supposed
to
do according to the back thing a unified
theory of psychological and ethical
egoism i don't think it's actually
providing that but it's doing something
a bit more interesting it's looking at a
lot of different
registers
and dimensions to human being trying to
trace out some key threads using some
conceptual tools
and connecting them to culture to lived
experiences to
other theory and to various dynamics
and it's it's making sense of them and
it's not
prioritizing
any single one of them as like the key
to understanding everything and i i like
that sort of
pluralism
so i wouldn't say that it's a unified
theory i would say it's a pluralistic
theory that has some unifying
tendencies to it
what else there's there's a lot of
really good examples in here
with analysis of them and i think that's
a strong point of the work helping you
understand what's going on so you know
i'll just give you one
uh
prime example he's talking about you
know
relationships and he says through my own
hysterics which i'm very familiar with i
can serve as an example of the shift in
self-interest in the detaching through
an exit and the difficulties within and
then he's got this sort of internal
dialogue that is in parentheses then he
says to let go of the partner is not
just to let go of the partner since the
desire of the other exists within one's
own desire the desire for the others the
desire in and for itself which is to say
desire articulated in the world rather
than simply held in consciousness
interestingly
my hysteric declaration that i miss her
so much when i further examine it is a
feeling that
she misses me or that she wants to be
with me sort of projected out there the
ego substance is still aligned in the
past relationship desire being both in
the world and internal creates the world
as something internal thus the i
which is missing her so much is in fact
her missing me the desire of the other
is my desire within self-interest this
is a very interesting analysis is it is
it something that's applicable to every
single case no of course not you have to
have a certain judiciousness in how you
pick and choose these things but it's
nice for
unpacking something there's a lot of
interesting insights that i think could
be developed further
along these these sorts of lines i'll
just give you an example of this because
i don't want to go into
too much detail so he's got this
discussion about anti-racism right
and he says
racism is not something
to be overcome but is itself the process
of overcoming
and he uses the example of martin luther
king's i have a dream speech and he says
um
that
you know
every time that you start making
something
go through
you only get
part of what you're looking for and this
is you know typically hegelian this is
also typically freudian too
um you can't entirely expunge racism you
can figure out how you're going to
deal with it and this connects us to
the good cause right
um
so
like he says the anti-racist ideal is
different than the i have a dream speech
in that the ideal contains a
timelessness the speech was delivered in
a certain time and place
and he talks about the more concreteness
of invoking you know coming to the
nation's capital to cash a check that
was uh in the constitution and the
declaration of independence as
promissory note right and and so there's
some really interesting ideas here being
worked with
that
probably could be
worked out
further but rosenstock is sort of
throwing the stuff in your lap and then
seeing what what you'll do with it
rather than spelling it out in a 500
page systematically organized book
the other thing that i do want to say
and signal is that there's a really good
discussion
of hegel going on
in chapters 18 through 20
and then in the final afterwards so
these are
absolute particularity
the unconscious extension of words and
ideals versus the other process the
unity of differentiating forces through
articulations
and you know one of the things that he's
really signaling here is that
um hegel
hegel is quite good at
getting at things materially he's not
he's not just an idealist but there is
this tendency within hegel
of taking
the the state
or whatever is going to be the highest
totality as
something like the conscience kingdom
events to which we all need to give up
our
self-interest we need to subordinate our
self-interest
and
you know he he views this wrote
rosenstock views this as problematic
he's also got a really great um
insight here
talking about um the peaceful subject
and that hegel and kant are both trying
to aim at
this as he calls it peace is not only
peace but contains within its ideal a
universal
super egoic
imperative to a regulation of a system
towards which antagonisms are reduced to
some degree right and so
you know
as he says both the hegelian subject and
the conscience subject can be said to be
followers of the maxim of peace which
finds an end in the unity of
consciousness with something in the
world something transcendently
transcendentally
ethical right and so something which
requires us again to leave leave
something of our self behind
i think that there's some
really good discussions about
hegel involved in this so
those are some some good points that i
think give you again a flavor of what's
contained in here
are there any aspects about this book
that i find problematic upon my second
and beyond reading of it yes i would say
so i mean
i i think that some things could have
been developed further and connections
could have been drawn out further with
each other
i also think and this is something that
i brought up in the the talking about
the style that for some people
this is going to be a rather either
difficult or frustrating book because
they're gonna be like what is this guy
talking about there's all the these
things that he's mentioning and i don't
know what they are
so
yeah i mean that's pretty much
unavoidable and that's not a problem by
the way just with continental philosophy
that is a problem with the analytic
philosophy
reading historical texts you know the
the cicero was complaining about the
stoics inventing vocabulary
way back in the ancient period so this
is not something new but you should be
uh you know forewarned that
there is going to be a good bit of
jargon and you probably you don't have
to like be a devoted hegelian or a
devoted freudian psychoanalyst to be
able to follow where things are going
but it certainly helps to
to have some understanding of these key
thinkers and i would say those are the
two most important hegel and and freud
right because some really fundamental
ideas are being
drawn out in there
he brings up nick land who is way way
further along the spectrum of reliance
on jargon than rosenstock is um
but you know he does bring up land and
and so you probably would need to know a
little bit about landonur to make sense
of what he's talking about there uh
he's also got some discussion along with
land of
sart and there's a discussion of marks
in here that requires that you
understand at least the basic points of
what's going on in one of marx's works
the
18th brewmere
where it's it's essentially about you
know power dynamics and stuff like that
i don't think you need an awful lot of
background in order to make sense of
this but it does help to some degree so
that could be problematic for some
readers
the notion of self-interest
is
so this is a strength of the work but
also i think a weakness of the work
you have to really piece together what
rosenstock is telling you
to get something like a
coherent
systematic understanding of all the
different dimensions of self-interest
that he's he's referring to
so i think there's really something
there but it could have been spelled out
further
um and you might actually need to like
make yourself like a chart or something
of the various allusions to
self-interest to see how they they all
fit together
the other thing that i'll say is i i
kind of would have liked to have seen
more engagement with earlier conceptions
of self-interest and associated notions
you know
for example
the the title itself evokes mark sterner
sterner is only mentioned towards the
end of the work
and we can think about other moderns as
well and other modern treatments of of
self-interest but we can also go back
further
and you know this is a very rich concept
in ancient philosophy
something that that aristotle talks
about plato talks about you know
plutarch talks about
um the epicureans had their own thing to
sort out and the stoics in particular
with the notion of wichiosis
and um you know love for self and all
these sorts of things it would have been
kind of
interesting to see some incorporation of
that um it that's
you know in some ways it's saying well
the book should have been a different
kind of book again that would have made
the book much much longer um so these
are fairly minor
um quibbles you could say rather than
damning criticisms or anything like that
about this book
all right so my final thoughts and my
recommendation i actually do recommend
this book for purchase
and i i would originally have said you
know i recommend this in a qualified way
for those who
you know are into the the types of
analysis and the sources and the jargon
and all that sort of stuff but actually
i kind of think this would be good for
other people to stretch their brains a
bit and so even if you don't know
anything at this point about
psychoanalysis or hegelian dialectics
you could probably
still you would still get something out
of a read of the book in part because
there's all these great examples and and
discussions and it would be an
opportunity
to stretch i mean this is this is an
interesting
work i think of it as something that's
kind of like a
more of a program or
a manifesto than a systematic work
or a unified theory or anything like
that but it's it's well worth reading
and it'll be thought provoking for
anybody who does get their hands on it
so i give this a a solid recommendation
you